TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to "Google
Developers Live." I'm Timothy
Jordan here at Google I/O. And
I'm sitting with a few friends
who built something
really fun for Glass.
Now, the reason we brought these
guys up here is because
I think the story is so cool.
And it's cool for a number
of different reasons.
The first one is that these
three guys are from three
different parts of
the country.
They all got together at our
Glass Foundry here in San
Francisco, built some really
cool Glassware,
and won first prize.
Not only that, the Glassware
that they built was based on
fun and having a good time.
It's the first game that
we have for Glass.
And I just wanted to talk about
that in more detail.
I think we should go through
and just have you guys
introduce yourselves.
And how about this?
Throw in, also, what's your
favorite thing about the
Mirror API?
Let's start with Song.
SONG ZHENG: Awesome.
My name is Song, and
I'm a developer
evangelist at TokBox.
And I've been playing around
with the Mirror API ever since
the Hackathon.
And what I really like
about it is that it's
very easy to use.
It's RESTful.
And there's a lot of client
support, so it doesn't matter
which language you're using.
There is support for it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And Jonathan.
JONATHAN GOTTFRIED: Hey, I'm
Jon Gottfried, and I'm a
developer evangelist
at Twilio.
And I've really enjoyed the
fact that the Mirror API
allows me to develop an
application and not have to
worry about the client, right?
I can assume that my application
is going to run as
expected because of
how it interacts
with the Glass device.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
And Rajiv.
RAJIV MAKHIJANI: Hi.
I'm Rajiv Makhijani.
I'm a software developer
at Hulu.
And I think the Glass API is
really cool because it lets
you develop what essentially
feels like a client
application the same way
you develop a web app.
So that you can release updates,
make changes, and
really affect it without having
to worry about software
updates or anything like that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
Before we start talking about
"Icebreaker" in more detail--
now, if you're playing the home
game and you'd like to
check out "Icebreaker,"
go to icebreaker.io.
It's going to be a lot more fun
if you're here at Google
I/O with Glass, but if you'd
like to take a look at their
cool graphics and see what
it's about, you can
play along that way.
Let's talk in more detail
about that.
But before we do, let's talk
about developing for Glass.
Now, what I think is crazy about
what you guys did was,
we had this conversation
a few weeks back,
wouldn't it be cool if.
We took what you guys built
for Glass Foundry, and
expanded it to a game that
people with Glass at I/O could
play, and could use to
meet each other.
And then you went off and
running developing.
And it was just a really
fast iteration process.
And I believe you're
still submitting
code, making it better.
Now, what is it about
the Mirror API--
FEMALE SPEAKER: I just
came by to say hi.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're going
to have a great show.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're live
on I/O, you know.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm not.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes, you are.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I know
that I'm not, no.
Am I?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Oh my god.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Just say hi.
It's OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hey.
Hey.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's going
to go down in history.
All right.
So back to what is it about
the Mirror API that makes
doing that kind of development,
that fast
iteration, and that fly by the
wire development so effective?
SONG ZHENG: So what
do you think, Jon?
JONATHAN GOTTFRIED: I think that
the interesting thing is
what Rajiv mentioned earlier,
that the Mirror API is really
a client application that you're
developing in the style
of a web application.
So we are deploying code in Ruby
and Python that runs on a
web server.
And the device simply connects
to it in a natural way that we
don't have to worry about.
So we can write our code and
deploy as often as we like,
and as often as we need to,
without having to interact
with the devices themselves.
We don't have to
push an update.
We don't have to have the
user do anything.
We can just write the code,
deploy it to our server, and
they will have the
latest version.
And it's really, really one of
the things I love about web
development.
And it's awesome to see that
ported to a client device.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
All right.
SONG ZHENG: I--
can I add to that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do you want
to add something?
Go for it.
SONG ZHENG: I just wanted to say
that the Mirror API, being
RESTful and all, really fits the
model of the whole concept
of timeline.
So you have a whole timeline
on your Google Glass.
When you send a post request,
you create a timeline.
And if you send an update
request, it updates it.
Working with the Mirror API,
it's something that you
understand right away, so you
don't have to do a whole
paradigm shift and learn an
entire new framework.
The whole concept of Mirror API
was very natural and easy
to pick up.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK.
Let's talk about the game.
And I think this is really
important, because Glass is
great for productivity.
It's great for sending email.
And there's also a lot of fun
stuff you can do on Glass,
like getting updates, and
sending pictures to my friends
on Google+.
But what I love about
"Icebreaker," it's just so
filled with whimsy.
Yeah?
I mean, you have a really good
time playing the game and
meeting new people
at the same time.
Rajiv, do you want to talk a
little bit about where that
idea came from, and why
it works at I/O?
RAJIV MAKHIJANI: Sure, yeah.
So the game kind of started
in a different place.
Originally, we were trying to
model what we were building
off of the game of "Assassins,"
because we
thought it would be cool
to use Glass to do
something like that.
And later we realized that,
hey, this is actually an
opportunity to be both a game
and also a way to meet people.
So that Glass isn't just about
productivity and receiving
notifications about different
information happening, but
it's also a way to meet other
people around you and actually
keep you more in touch with the
real world, rather than
sucking you back into your
electronic devices.
So we thought that would
be really cool
way to approach it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's great.
And what I love about that is
that Glass isn't about being
immersed in a device.
It's about connecting you more
with the people and places
around you.
And I think "Icebreaker"
does that really well.
JONATHAN GOTTFRIED: And I think
that while we're in the
Explorer program, it's a very
tight-knit group that's
already collaborating online,
and already having all of
these interactions within
the developer community.
And it's awesome to
kind of transmit
that to the real world.
It's already a small, tight-knit
group of people,
and it's awesome to see them
meet and interact in person.
SONG ZHENG: If I have Google
Glass, and you're wearing
Google Glass, we have
something in
common right away.
We're both passionate about
technology, right?
So why not build an app that
brings all our interests
together, so that you meet
another person who also has
the same passion for technology
that you have and
build a whole community
like that.
And as Glass expands, the
community expands, and
everybody becomes
one big family.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I like that.
Now, you've been at our Sandbox
over there in the
Glass booth, which means
you've been demoing.
People have been coming up
and asking you questions.
And you probably also got some
people with Glass who have
started using "Icebreaker."
How is it going at the
conference?
Are people using it?
Are they meeting each other?
RAJIV MAKHIJANI: Yeah,
it's been great.
I mean, initially there was a
little bit of Wi-Fi problems,
but I think people have really
started picking up
and playing the game.
We've seen a lot of people
actually find
people and meet people.
And a lot of people who get
really excited about it,
because it's one of the few
interactive things you can do
with Glass right now that is
beyond just productivity.
So I think it's been quite
successful from our opinion.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's
awesome.
SONG ZHENG: I've been getting
updates constantly.
Hey, this person is
close to you.
Do you want to meet them?
And so I've been asking random
people, hey, are you Antonio,
are you Dave?
And eventually I found
my target.
And then it happened to also
be Jon's target, so we
introduced him to Antonio.
And we have never met each other
before, but we became
friends right away.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So we just have
a couple minutes left.
Let me ask you one
short question.
Give me a quick answer.
What do you think's next
for "Icebreaker"?
Do you think this is something
that you might keep going
with, and people will keep
using to meet each other?
RAJIV MAKHIJANI: I think we want
to just explore where it
goes, like see what people's
feedback is based on using it.
See how many people actually
have Glass and
are in the same proximity.
And then we can consider either
expanding it to other
devices, or if there's enough
Glass devices, then maybe
figuring out ways to
recommend people
that have common interests.
If everyone has Glass, or not
necessarily everyone, but like
a large percentage of people,
then it would be really cool
to actually introduce you to
people that have other shared
interests, not just that
they have Glass.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool.
JONATHAN GOTTFRIED: I really
think that as the developer
tools expand for Glass, and as
we can start building more
advanced features, that we're
going to expand "Icebreaker"
to match that.
We really want to be on the
cutting edge of Glass
development.
And we want our application to
kind of embody the best and
the most interesting
uses of Glass.
And so I think that as we have
access to more features and
more functionality, we're
going to integrate
that into our app.
SONG ZHENG: I think that as
Glass becomes more mainstream,
and we start getting more
people using it, we're
eventually going to maybe add
like interest fields, and
match people of same
interests together.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
SONG ZHENG: And then once we're
at that point, it would
make sense to build an Android
app that goes along with it.
So it welcomes other
players as well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, thank you guys so much for
joining me here, and for
building on Glass.
And thank you out there
for joining us.
If you'd like to know more
information about building on
Glass,
developers.google.com/glass.
We're also answering questions
on Stack Overflow, and of
course, on Google+.
This has been "Google Developers
Live" at I/O. We'll
be back at 6:00 PM with
a talk with Gmail.